wir überwachen und sichern unseren
luftraum 24 stunden 365 tage im jahr
von kleinauf unbedingt den eurofighter
fliegen
darum habe mich beworben bei militär
adaptern dort maturiert bin ganz normal
eingerückt zum bundesheer und habe
während dem studium an der
theresianischen militärakademie die
selektions schritte zum piloten gemacht
und hab dann mit der fliegerischen
ausbildung angefangen und bin dieses
jahr fertig geworden als einsatzpiloten
am europatag
überhaupt praxis hat das ist die aktive
luftraumüberwachung und sprechen der
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz
machen wir salopp gesagt dass in der
luft was die polizei am boden machen
das ist eine sehr große ehre des eigenen
luftfahrzeug oder den eigenen kampfjet
fürs eigene land zu fliegen und die luft
wort zu behaupten
man kann sich das so vorstellen der
österreichische luftraum ist ab einer
gewissen höhe rund ums zentrum flughäfen
freigabe wichtig ist ein luftfahrzeug
drinnen dass diese erlaubnis nicht hat
beziehungsweise der pro kontakt zu
diesem luftfahrzeug nicht hergestellt
werden kann werden wir alarmiert und
untersuchen dieses luftfahrzeug
durch das dass wir durch so viele
ausbildungen im ausland gehen und das
sehr sehr lange dauert ist natürlich der
erste flug im heimischen luftfahrzeug
über heimischen boden ein ganz großer
schritt und eine ganz groß auf